TO CALL BACK SOME OF THE
EXECUTIVE POWER THAT HE HAS
CEASED FOR HIMSELF IN RECENT
YEARS.
>> Bret: A CONOR POWELL IN OUR
MIDDLE EAST NEWSROOM.
PLEASE JOIN ME SUNDAY NIGHT FOR
A SPECIAL LOOK AT THE HISTORIC
POINT IN TIME WHEN RONALD REAGAN
BROUGHT THE MESSAGE OF PEACE AND
FREEDOM TO WHAT WAS THEN THE
SOVIET UNION.
THE PROGRAM IS CALLED "THREE
DAYS IN MOSCOW."
IT'S BASED ON MY BOOK, AND HERE
IS A PREVIEW WITH THE MAN WHO
SERVED AS THE PRESIDENT'S PRESS
SECRETARY AT THE TIME.
>> I GIVE A SPEECH AT MOSCOW
UNIVERSITY WHERE THE PRESIDENT
WANTED TO TALK ABOUT FREEDOM OF
SPEECH.
>> SET THE STAGE FOR THAT ONE.
>> WHEN I WALKED IN THE DOOR, I
WALKED INTO THE HEAD OF THE
CHURCH WITH THIS HUGE STATUE OF
LENIN AND A LECTERN WHICH WAS
SET UP FOR REAGAN WITH A LIGHT
IN FRONT OF IT.
>> YOU WERE THINKING IT WAS A
BAD THING?
>> I THINK IT WAS A HORRIBLE
THING.
BUT PRESIDENT REAGAN SAW IT AS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO DELIVER THIS
MESSAGE.
HIS JOKE LATER WAS, HOW GREAT
WAS IT TO HAVE LENIN BACK TO
STARE AT MY BACKSIDE FOR AN HOUR
AND A HALF?
BUT IT TURNED OUT TO BE THE
PERFECT FORUM FOR HIM TO DELIVER
HIS MESSAGE.
>> Bret: THE STUDENTS FILED IN
AND SETTLE DOWN.
HE WARMED UP HIS AUDIENCE BY
WISHING THEM SUCCESS IN THEIR
OWN LANGUAGE.
>> I KNOW YOU MUST BE VERY BUSY
THIS WEEK STUDYING AND TAKING
HER FINAL EXAMINATIONS.
SO LET ME JUST SAY -- [SPEAKING
IN FOREIGN LANGUAGE]